das hier ist das zweite Video der
siebenteiligen Interviewserie mit den
Teilnehmern von Seven vs Staffel 2 viel
Spaß mit dem Interview von Sabrina
genau also seit ich weiß dass ich an der
zweiten Staffel teilnehme habe ich mich
komplett vorbereitet ich habe Youtube
Videos geguckt ich habe mir sofort alle
Bücher die es irgendwie auf Amazon gab
bestellt habe die durchgewälzt habe mich
ein Themen auseinandergesetzt habe auch
ganz viel ausprobiert habe auch
teilweise Videos darüber gedreht habe
aber auch noch mal privat ganz ganz viel
ausprobiert habe mich auch damit
auseinandergesetzt wie ist es halt
wirklich alleine zu sein wie ist es
irgendwie meine Nacht draußen zu
schlafen so grundsätzlich weiß ich ja
wie es ist draußen zu schlafen aber halt
nicht alleine das heißt ich habe mich
schon sehr sehr intensiv versucht darauf
vorzubereiten und mich vor allem auch in
diese Situation reinzudenken also ich
glaube das ist noch mal dass man halt
versucht sich mal so ein bisschen zu
fühlen was kommt da auf einen zu wie ist
der erste Tag wenn man ankommt was für
Emotionen kommen da ähm könnte man sich
überfordert fühlen was für Probleme
bekommen da und genau also ich habe
schon versucht mich sehr sehr gut darauf
vorzubereiten ja der drop of War in
dieser Staffel deutlich extremer erzähl
uns bitte wie der Tag für dich
abgelaufen ist und wie du ihn
wahrgenommen hast ja also wir wurden ja
dann gar nicht so früh geweckt ich hatte
irgendwie gedacht wir werden so um 4 Uhr
morgens heute die Polter aus dem Bett
geworfen war dann eigentlich fand ich
relativ entspannt und dann war es halt
super aufregend ich habe halt schon
gemerkt man es kommt halt so eine
gewisse Nervosität raus ich war
eigentlich relativ entspannt aber
ja diesmal war das schon so ein bisschen
oder ab dann war es schon so ein
bisschen nervöser und heftiger wenn man
nicht so genau weiß was kommt da
wirklich genau auf einen zu ähm ja dann
war es ja so dass wir ins Flugzeug sind
irgendwie ich habe das Gefühl wir hatten
aber so total den Zusammenhalt im Team
ja und dann sind wir halt auf dem
Flugzeug gesprungen echt dazu jetzt
einfach Augen zu einfach raus ich bin
halt nicht ganz so also mir ist es nicht
ganz so lieb aber ja ich habe dann
einfach in dem Moment gesagt okay komm
Johannes so du gehst jetzt einen rüber
dann raus und gesprungen und dann war
ich erstmal total euphorisch als ich
dann angekommen bin auf der Insel dass
ich dachte okay jetzt bin ich halt
wirklich hier jetzt
bin ich halt so für mich jetzt total
selbstbestimmt ich kann jetzt machen
habe halt jetzt meine Ruhe habe auch
dann angefangen wirklich direkt
angefangen meinen Shelter zu bauen in
step 1 Step 2 aber ich habe gemerkt ich
war halt noch total euphorisch und
aufgedreht aufgewirbelt und das hat sich
dann ab Tag zwei so ein bisschen gelegt
dass ich halt ein bisschen ruhiger wurde
ja was hattest du für ein Gefühl als wir
auf diesem winzigen landing Stream
ankamen du die Heelys gesehen hast und
wusstest dass ihr aus dem fliegenden
Helikoptern springen müsst ich habe
schon ein bisschen vermutet dass wir
nicht mit dem Boot ausgesetzt werden
sondern das ist ein bisschen
dramatischer wird und dass wir eben
tatsächlich aus dem Helikopter springen
müssen ähm ich war den ganzen Flug über
eigentlich relativ entspannt ich fand es
im ersten Moment so ein bisschen komisch
weil die Türen ja rechts und links offen
waren und der Wind ähm dann dadurch
Gefecht ist durch das Flugzeug und dann
links runter gucken konnte und ja dann
war allerdings irgendwie total tief man
hat den Dschungel gesehen aber ja der
Flug an sich hat dann irgendwie total
Spaß gemacht war eine coole Erfahrung
und beim rausspringen war es dann halt
wirklich so Augen zu einfachen ein Sitz
rüber sich auf dieses Podest stellen und
dann einfach Augen zu und runterspringen
bin dann auch auf dem Hintern gelandet
hat auch kurz weh aber dann ist man
durch dieses Salzwasser total schnell
wieder aufgetaucht und dann ist man
einfach völlig unter Adrenalin also man
macht dann wirklich nur noch step eins
der zweite drei und ähm ja startet dann
halt so ins Geschehen rein wie war's
dann für dich als so ein Land gekommen
bist und wegfliegen sehen was waren da
so deine ersten Gefühle
also ich war am Anfang als ich auf der
Insel angekommen bin total überwältigt
und auch sprachlos
also ich wusste gar nicht so richtig was
da jetzt gerade passiert das hat dann so
ungefähr eine halbe Stunde für gleich
gedauert dann habe ich halt angefangen
so ein bisschen zu gucken wo bin ich
hier bin nach rechts gegangen da mussten
wir auch unseren Packsack suchen und man
die Gegenstände zu kommen und habe dann
da ja mich so ein bisschen orientiert
bin dann mal rechts links lang gegangen
habe mich aber ehrlich gesagt von
Sekunde eins an meinem Spot sehr sehr
wohl gefühlt ich habe relativ schnell
gesehen dass ich eine Süßwasserquelle
habe also einen kleinen Fluss der halt
glasklar war und ähm ja habe dann daraus
getrunken habe gemerkt das schmeckt wie
normales Wasser habe gesehen dass da
Müll war und dann war ich eigentlich
total begeistert weil ich da oder
erleichtert weil ich wusste ab diesem
Zeitpunkt ich kann diese 7 Tage halt
wirklich schaffen also so diese größte
Angst die man hatte dass man nicht genug
Trinkwasser hatte wurde eine in dem
Moment dann eben genommen ja und dadurch
habe ich mich dann auf einmal total
sicher gefühlt und ähm ja habe mich dann
irgendwie gefreut ob das was jetzt kommt
war aber auch so ein bisschen unter
Druck dass ich dachte ich muss jetzt
halt auch anfangen mein Shelter zu bauen
und mich in sich herumgebung zu bringen
ja die ersten von euren Tagen waren noch
ziemlich schön es hat mal geregnet
grundsätzlich war gutes Wetter bis an
Tag 3 dann richtig angefangen hat zu
blitzen und zu donnern und das zu einem
wirklichen Tropensturm kam wie war das
für dich und wie hast du das
wahrgenommen also ich muss sagen bei dem
ersten Tropensturm war mein shelter
oben noch
einen Kopf also es war die linke Seite
war fertig die rechte Seite war so zur
Hälfte fertig das heißt ich lag während
des Sturms und während des Regens unter
der einen Hälfte von meinem Shelter
wurde also entsprechend komplett nass
der ganze Donner der Blitz der Wind und
so weiter das hat mir nichts ausgemacht
also ich hatte jetzt keine Angst vor
diesem Widrigkeiten
ich habe mich sogar am Anfang noch extra
so in Regen gestellt noch so geil habe
ich so geduscht und habe es übelst
abgefeiert ähm habe dann aber irgendwann
gemerkt dass ich total angefangen habe
zu frieren und ich habe gefroren
gefroren und immer mehr und immer mehr
und immer mehr und ich lag dann da unter
meinem halbfertigen Shelter und habe
dann irgendwie gedacht oh Gott es wird
irgendwann aufhören jeder Regen hört
einfach auf aber wann so und ja habe das
dann irgendwie ausgehalten lag dann da
total zerfroren und ja das war dann halt
so ein bisschen wo ich gemerkt habe okay
das wird hart die ganze Zeit wird hart
ja okay krass war das dann auch so dein
größtes Problem und wenn nicht was war
dein größtes Problem für mich war
tatsächlich das größte Problem meine
körperliche Verfassung also ich habe ja
bis zum vierten Tag nichts gegessen
trinken hatte ich die ganze Zeit das war
nicht das Problem ich habe aber
eigentlich ab Tag eins gemerkt da noch
nicht so schlimm das wird dann immer
schlimmer aber dass mir ganz ganz
schwindelig war also ich egal wenn ich
mich irgendwie mal ein bisschen
schneller bemerkt habe oder von unten
nach oben gekommen bin mir wurde jedes
Mal total schwindelig ich hatte kaum
Kraft
mir wurde teilweise auch wirklich
schwarz vor Augen wenn ich eine heftige
Bewegung gemacht habe und das hat mir
mit der Zeit schon zu schaffen gemacht
weil ich dann immer so ein bisschen
gucken musste das Shelter ist ja sehr
Energie also braucht man halt sehr viel
Energie um das zu bauen und musste dann
immer gucken okay was kann ich jetzt für
Kleinigkeiten machen vielleicht Schnüre
machen was dann wieder weniger Energie
benötigt das heißt ich musste da halt
echt immer so ein bisschen Haushalten ja
wie viel Energie brauche ich jetzt dafür
dass ich halt jetzt nicht irgendwie ja
total Schwindelanfall bekommen aber ja
das war glaube ich das größte Problem
und hätte ich auch nicht so erwartet
also das habe ich tatsächlich vollkommen
unterschätzt was war dann im Endeffekt
der Grund für den Ausscheiden warum hast
du dich am Tag 6 dafür entschieden bis
hierhin und nicht weiter ich möchte
abholt werden ja also ich hatte an dem
Abend davor schon gemerkt die Flut kommt
und
bei mir war es tatsächlich so dass mein
kompletter Spot schon fast komplett
überfüllt also mit Wasser gefüllt weil
ich hatte noch so ein kleines Mini
Stückchen Plateau wo halt das dann noch
trocken war wo die Flug noch nicht
hingekommen ist und ich habe dann schon
gemerkt okay die nächste Nacht wird
wahrscheinlich noch heftiger ja dann saß
ich in meinem Shelter habe halt die
Nacht abgewartet dass man irgendwie ganz
zusammengekauert und habe dann ja
gewartet bis es dann um 4 Uhr morgens
kurz bevor es hell wird wirklich
losgehen und dann habe ich gemerkt okay
die Wellen kommen und immer stärker und
immer stärker und
war auch schon so ein bisschen nervös
weil ich ja von der Nacht davor schon
wusste was mich erwartet
und ja dann war es halt so dann hat mich
die erste Welle irgendwie das Shelter
erreicht und dann kam die nächste Welle
unterstellter und dann kam immer mehr
und irgendwann war es halt wirklich so
dass ich bis zu meiner Hüfte komplett
mit Wasser vollgespült war und mein Bett
halt immer hoch und runter und ich hatte
in dem Moment wirklich Angst dass mein
Shelter zusammenbricht über mir
zusammenbricht und mich erschlägt oder
was auch immer ähm ja und dann saß ich
da irgendwie in der linken Hand so die
Sachen die ich noch brauchte den Rest
habe ich am Abend davor schon
zusammengekettet oder festgekettet das
halt nichts weggespült werden kann ich
habe mir auch am Abend davor extra Sport
überlegt wo ich im Notfall hingehen kann
der so ein bisschen erhöht ist ähm aber
auch der wurde überspült tatsächlich und
ja dann saß ich da halt und dann war
halt tatsächlich auf einmal so krank
so ein bisschen ein dann halt wieder
krank was machst du jetzt entweder gehst
du raus und wirst von der Welle
mitgerissen oder du bleibst halt drin
sitzen ähm ja und dann hat er wieder
gekracht und dann ist halt tatsächlich
mein Schalter über zusammengebrochen ich
habe in der rechten Hand irgendwie noch
so diese richeline gehalten und habe
dann wirklich in dem Moment einfach gar
auch gar nicht mehr gedacht irgendwie
einfach nur noch gehandelt meine Sachen
genommen bin halt aus diesem Shelter
dann ist es auch komplett
zusammengefallen und stand und da ganz
bedröppelt so die ganze Nacht auf diesem
Plateau meine Füße komplett überspült
und
[Musik]
das wäre jetzt nicht für mich der Grund
gewesen warum ich aufgebe weil das war
dann ja vorbei ähm für mich war der
Grund warum ich gesagt habe ich lasse
das weil ich Angst vor der nächsten
Nacht hatte weil ich nicht wusste wird
die nächsten Nacht noch schlimmer wird
die Flut noch stärker und es war halt
bei mir schon alles überspültig hatte
kein Shelter mehr der mich irgendwie für
Regen schützt ich hatte
nichts mehr was mich verwünscht ich
hätte halt wenn dann im Dschungel
schlafen müssen auf so einer schrägen er
hätte mir dann irgendwie einen Shelter
bauen müssen hatte ich schon keine
Energie mehr und ähm ja also die einzige
Möglichkeit die ich dann halt in dem
Moment gesehen habe ist dass ich halt
eine ganze Nacht irgendwie im Dschungel
einfach nur da stehe und warte das ist
halt irgendwie vorbei ist ja und das war
dann halt für mich irgendwie der Grund
dass ich gesagt habe
ich drücke jetzt den Knopf und gehe
jetzt und war für mich auch völlig fein
damit also ich war wirklich happy damit
habe auch jetzt die Tage noch mal
überlegt ob es noch irgendwas hätte
gegeben was ich noch hätte anders machen
können genau bin aber wirklich fein
damit also es ist okay ich hätte ich
ärgere mich schon ein bisschen weil ich
weiß ich hätte diese 7 Tage schaffen
können wäre das nicht das macht mich
schon ein bisschen traurig weil dieser
Moment mit allen Teilnehmern gemeinsam
abgeholt zu werden das war halt die
ganze Zeit mein Ziel und diesen Moment
konnte ich jetzt halt nicht erleben und
das macht mich schon traurig und
enttäuscht mich ein bisschen aber
trotzdem glaube ich für mich dass es in
dem Moment die richtige Entscheidung war
ja konntest du dieser gesamten Erfahrung
irgendwas positives abgewinnen und wenn
ja welche Erfahrungen nimmst du mit also
es war für mich insgesamt trotzdem eine
positive Erfahrung auch wenn es nicht
das Ergebnis war was ich mir erhofft
habe trotzdem weiß ich dass ich für mich
halt an meine Grenzen gegangen bin und
auch darüber hinaus es gab ganz viele
Momente wo ich so dachte never ever ist
das einfach zu krass ich friere oder
auch dieser Schwindel die ganze Zeit
von daher war es für mich tatsächlich
eine sehr sehr positive Erfahrung ich
habe für mich auch privat noch so ein
paar Themen reflektiert die ich für mich
mitnehme es gab auch so ein paar kleine
Momente die positiv waren wie als ich
Wale gesehen habe oder das erste mal so
eine Kokosnuss getrunken habe von daher
insgesamt war es ja sehr sehr positiv
für mich dann herzlichen Glückwunsch für
diese sehr sehr gute Leistung vielen
Dank dass du angetreten bist und viel
Spaß zurück in der Zivilisation danke